et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Dominique Faure bonjour bon merci
beaucoup d'être avec nos amis délégués
aux collectivités territoriales et à la
ruralité en étant ça pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse régionale représentée par
Stéphane Vernet de westfrance bonjour
Stéphane bonjour
Dominique fort Emmanuel Macron reçoit
aujourd'hui plus de 200 m victimes de
violence d'agressions est-ce qu'il y
aura de nouvelles mesures pour les
protéger ses mères
oui bien sûr nous avons depuis le 17 mai
travailler parce que le 17 mai nous
avons annoncé un certain nombre de
mesures et qui sont réalités aujourd'hui
sur le territoire et nous travaillons
sur de nouvelles mesures qui seront
annoncées cette semaine pour certaines
Emmanuel
Macron mais je pense que aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment le temps de la
reconnaissance pour Emmanuel Macron et
c'est le temps je pense de l'écoute sur
leur perception de ce que les mères
vivent sur le terrain c'est le temps du
dialogue et puis peut-être le temps de
certaines annonces mais elles sont assez
nombreuses et donc je pense que il en
annoncera peut-être quelques-unes mais
peut-être pas toutes en tout cas en fin
de semaine nous
nous annoncerons de façon extrêmement
précise les quatre axes autour desquels
nous travaillons alors la protection
juridique et la protection psychologique
extrêmement importante des mères la
protection physique en complément de ce
que nous avons déjà déployé de nouvelles
mesures judiciaires et puis se
rapprochement entre les maires et les
parquets donc ces quatre axes encore une
fois que je peux pas vous dévoiler là
mais en plus de ce qui a déjà été
annoncé par par la première je vous dis
c'est-à-dire que ça allait pas assez
loin ce que vous avez annoncé après la
décision après la démission du maire de
Saint-Brévin après la démission du maire
de Saint-Brévin on a annoncé vous savez
les 3400 gendarmes et policiers sur le
terrain le aller vers les mers le
dispositif à l'âme se Pack Sécurité que
que votre collègue a extrêmement bien
décrit juste avant mais oui bien sûr
nous voulons aller plus loin avec des
mesures qui pour certaines sont
réglementaires pour d'autres sont
juridiques donc il nous faudra attendre
une niche parlementaire pour faire voter
par exemple le fait que qui s'attaque à
un élu et sanctionné de la même façon
que qui s'attaque un gendarme ou un
policier donc là c'est plutôt sur le
mois d'octobre qu'on aura cette niche
qui nous permettra j'ai déjà dit le
mi-mai que vous voulez aligner les
sanctions pénales des atteints sur les
atteintes aux forces de leur est-ce que
vous irez encore plus loin dans ces
annonces oui vous resterez sur le sur
sur cette échelle sur le plan de la
sanction je pense que aligner des
sanctions à celles aux policier ou
gendarmes c'est déjà beaucoup vous savez
c'est autour de 100000 euros 7 ans
d'emprisonnement ferme donc non je on
n'ira pas plus loin et par contre oui il
y a un certain nombre de sujets comme la
protection fonctionnelle que l'on veut
rendre automatique mais l'idée n'est pas
de vous dévoiler il veut dire
concrètement mais ce qui veut dire que
les mers seront protégés automatiquement
sans délibération en Conseil Municipal
parce que parfois certains hésitent à le
faire donc l'idée c'est qu'il soit
protégé ce plan fonctionnel
automatiquement
Emmanuel Macron a dit qu'il voulait
comprendre en profondeur les raisons qui
ont conduit à ces événements et souhaite
un travail minutieux et le plus et plus
long terme est-ce que vous allez
participer à ce genre de choses et
comment est-ce que vous comprenez ça
veut dire qu'il y a il y a tout un
travail à long terme et de second rideau
à faire aussi
il y a mon avis de temps vous avez tout
à fait raison il y a le temps de la
protection aujourd'hui et vous avez
évoqué et que j'ai évoqué et puis il y a
le temps de la réflexion pour comprendre
effectivement d'où l'intérêt de ce
dialogue qu'il veut nouer avec les mères
ces quartiers politiques de la ville ça
il y a beaucoup de d'argent qui ont été
injectés ces dernières années avec
beaucoup de gouvernements qui se sont
succédés et donc la réflexion c'est
celle qui va viser à à se dire comment
on peut capitaliser sur tout ce qui a
été fait parce que vous entendez
sénateurs députés dire à quel point ça
serait bien pire si on n'avait pas fait
tout ce que nous avons fait mais à quel
point il faut réinterroger et voir dans
quelle mesure
il ne faut pas faire certaines choses
autrement d'autres les prolongés donc
oui je pense que le Président de la
République va nous associer à cette
réflexion au premier rang desquels
Christophe Vichy ministre de la cohésion
des territoires et la transition
écologique Olivier Klein et ce travail
que j'ai fait sur la ruralité pendant
six mois d'observation de rencontres de
compréhension apporter les éléments sur
la ruralité je pense que ce travail peut
être tout à fait fait dans les quartiers
de politique de la ville un travail de
terrain pour essayer de comprendre
comment on peut encore une fois
poursuivre mais aussi réinventer de
nouvelles pratiques il y aura à peu près
combien de mesures qui seront annoncées
non mais combien de mesures là vous
dites qu'il y aura de nouvelles mesures
annoncées à la fois par Emmanuel Macron
puis j'imagine par par Elisabeth borde
ça représente à peu près combien de
nouvelles mesures dans les quatre axes
dont vous nous avez autour d'une
quinzaine une quinzaine mesure autour de
ces attaques de ces quatre axes
Elisabeth borne elle avait annoncé lors
de la présentation du plan ruralité
qu'il y aurait de nouvelles mesures dont
vous nous parlez ce matin est-ce que ce
qui s'est passé ce week-end à
L'Haÿ-les-Roses et l'agression de la
famille du maire Vincent Jean Brun a
fait modifier ces mesures est-ce que du
coup vous en avez durci certaines est-ce
que vous en avez rajouté d'autres alors
oui d'abord je veux avoir une pensée
pour aussi la mère de Pontoise Stéphanie
vaneux
pour bien sûr Vincent Jean Brun nous
étions et pour leur famille et
ce que j'ai énormément apprécié c'est
que au-delà de la protection de leur
famille mais cette détermination à
rester à faire front et je pense que les
mères sont vraiment notre une grande
part de notre République et il
nous faut évidemment les protéger ce que
nous faisons aujourd'hui en fait il y
aura des mesures aussi pour les familles
parce que là on l'a vu le maire se
trouver dans sa mairie c'est son
domicile qui a été attaqué avec sa femme
et ses enfants à l'intérieur est-ce
qu'il y aura aussi des mesures prévues
là-dessus c'est déjà le cas sur le plan
de la protection aujourd'hui à la fois
le domicile des maires bien sûr les
mairies
sont extrêmement protégés par nos
gendarmes et par nos petits et par nos
policiers combien aujourd'hui il y a de
mairies ou de domiciles de mer qui sont
sous protection avec ce qui s'est passé
ces derniers jours
moi je dirais que il y a eu 100 mairies
qui ont été fortement dégradés il y a
beaucoup de menaces beaucoup de menaces
de la protection ce que nous appelons
rapprocher à la fois des mères
de par le dialogue qui s'est noué entre
les gendarmes le préfet et les maires de
façon très amplifiée je veux pas vous
donner de chiffres mais il y a un très
son nombre bien plus que les 100 qui ont
été
agressés
endommagé et un grand nombre de maires
qui sont
protégés en fait sur les centres ça
représente à peu près combien de mer
aujourd'hui qui sont protégées
l'importance de ce centre de lutte que
nous avons créé ils vise à inviter les
maires à d'abord signaler très tôt et
qu'est-ce qui fait que un préfet et nos
gendarmes ou nos policiers décident de
protéger amer mais c'est le fait que il
y a un certain nombre de faits de
plaintes qui ont été déposées qui
s'accélèrent avec une violence qui se
rapproche et donc j'invite évidemment
les mères à signaler extrêmement tôt et
et à échanger à dialoguer avec nos
gendarmes et nos préférés vous nous avez
dit sans mérite qui ont été attaqués
pendant ces émeutes est-ce que vous
savez combien de maires ont été agressés
depuis le début
et heureusement heureusement très peu je
vous ai cité la mère de Pontoise mais
voilà de l'ordre de 5 grands maximum et
heureusement aujourd'hui
l'épouse du maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses et
celle qui est le plus touché
mais je veux quand même rappeler que
au-delà de de ces atteintes aux élus
eux-mêmes qui ne représentent d'une
façon générale et indépendamment de ces
émeutes que 5% de nos faits signaler et
beaucoup beaucoup de menaces beaucoup de
cyber violence beaucoup d'atteintes ont
bien et autour de 5% d'atteinte aux
personnes et heureusement mais quand
même 90 postes de police
90 écoles 50 gendarmerie donc le nombre
d'atteintes au bien et absolument énorme
qu'est-ce que ça quel coup ça représente
pour les communes est-ce que vous êtes
en capacité d'évaluer nous donner une
fourchette combien ça va coûter pour les
collectivités on a comme réf érence
2005 où le un budget de réparation de
remise en état et avoisiné les 200
millions ce qui est le 5 voilà oui mais
aujourd'hui on est en train d'avoir
remonter le niveau
de d'investissement qui va être
nécessaire qui va prendre
tout de suite Gérald Darmanin a annoncé
hier des jeunes première enveloppe de 20
millions d'euros tout de suite pour
réparer et remplacer les caméras puisque
là on est vraiment dans l'urgence et
l'absolument
de vidéoprotection absolument
ensuite le montant des réparations ça va
nous remonter au fil de du temps mais il
ne faudra quand même des évaluations
précises la première chose c'est
évidemment que les mairies se retournent
vers leur compagnie d'assurance et puis
on ne laissera aucune mairie au bord du
chemin
toutes n'ont pas toutes les mairies
n'ont pas de compagnies d'assurance
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire pour ces
mairie là
toutes les mairies ont des compagnies
qui n'ont pas forcément
de contrats d'assurance mais à ma
connaissance la majorité d'entre elles
ont un contrat d'assurance est-ce que ça
veut dire du coup que vous comptez sur
les assureurs ou est-ce que l'État va
débloquer en fond d'urgence pour aider
les collectivités touchées nous
travaillons sur ce fond d'urgence
effectivement pour venir compléter les
dégradations qui ont eu lieu surnommés
mais je veux quand même dire un mot même
le fond d'urgence ça sera les mairies
font remonter à l'état leur dégâts et
elles seront remboursées ou est-ce que
il va y avoir une enveloppe qui va être
dédiée répartie entre chaque commune
comment ça va fonctionner les deux
choses vont être menées concomitamment
le fond d'urgence nous y travaillons et
on sera en mesure de l'annoncer très
très rapidement en parallèle de ça les
préfets avec nos maires travaillent sur
un montant estimé de réparation et de
remise en service parce que l'objectif
c'est quand même de délivrer du service
public le plus vite possible mais le
reste à charge une fois les compagnies
d'assurance ayant indiqué quel est le
montant et bien c'est ce reste à charge
que l'on va
que l'on va accompagner mais je vois
déjà certaines régions certaines
départements dire au maire qu'il
viendront aussi accompagner la
réparation de ces dégradations donc ce
reste à charge bien nous le
travaillerons départements et régions et
état maintenant la main vous êtes aussi
en charge de la ruralité Dominique Faure
on l'a dit est-ce que ça vous a surpris
que des villes moyennes des petites
villes soient touchées par ses émeutes
qui cette fois n'ont pas concerné
uniquement les grandes villes et les
banlieues oui ça m'a touché c'est vrai
que en majorité ce sont des quartiers
politiques de la ville mais il y a
effectivement quelques communes qui ont
été dégradées
vous savez on a un phénomène qui part un
petit peu de partout et il est
extrêmement difficile d'y trouver une
logique même si la mort de Naël est au
départ et à l'origine des premières
violences on a bien vu que dans les
formes de violences on s'est attaqué
même à des centres sociaux on s'est
attaqué à des commerces on a pillé des
commerces on s'est attaqué à des
symboles de la République donc c'est
extrêmement difficile
d'en tirer des enseignements et de se
dire pourquoi en réalité
ils se sont aussi attaqués à des
symboles de la République je pense que
il faut se réjouir que en ruralité il y
a une forme de respect de la République
il y a une forme de
reconnaissance de ce que la République
apporte à nos concitoyens qui fait que
aujourd'hui on en a peu eu en tout cas
oui ça m'a un peu attristé de voir que y
compris des petites communes avaient été
agressés est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il
va y avoir de telle mesure ajoutée au
plan ruralité que vous avez annoncé il y
a quelques temps non parce que tout
simplement on est sur le champ de la
violence faite aux élus pour ma part et
c'est général c'est tous les élus qui
bénéficieront de ce champ de protection
et de réparation
et pas plus
les quartiers de politique de la ville
qui évidemment ont besoin d'être plus
que protégé et mais aussi les plus
petites communes c'est une action que
nous conduisons pour toutes les communes
quelle que soit leur taille vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure les 3400
référents que vous voulez mettre en
place pour pour accompagner les les élus
est-ce que le réseau a déjà été
totalement déployé il est en cours la
réponse est oui et pourquoi aussi
rapidement mais tout simplement parce
qu'il y avait déjà des gendarmes et des
policiers qui étaient des référents élus
la différence c'est que ils sont passés
référents violents fait aux élus et ils
ont été formés pour ça ils l'avaient été
et ça a été accéléré et la grande
différence c'est le aller vers c'est à
dire que il pour l'instant on quasi fait
le tour chacun sur sa circonscription
est allé voir
les mères qui dépendent de cette
est-ce que c'est références en fait sont
pleinement opérationnels et est-ce que
le fait de les avoir vous permettre de
mieux accompagner les élus dans cette
période de crise maintenant là
aujourd'hui oui ça c'est une réalité moi
j'en suis à plus de 80 déplacements la
semaine dernière 5 jours 5 déplacements
et j'échange évidemment à chaque fois
avec préfet gendarmes et élu et ce que
je constate c'est que cet aller vers il
est totalement réalité c'est à dire que
précédemment les maires avaient le
numéro de portable ou de gendarmes
aujourd'hui il se parle très
régulièrement leur famille est
évidemment au cœur de la réflexion et du
travail qui conduisent ensemble donc moi
je vois bien que
cette allée vers a fonctionné et il est
aujourd'hui réalité parmi les autres
mesures mises en place par le
gouvernement il y a des formations pour
les élus qui sont dispensés par leur
aide par le GIGN pour les aider
justement à gérer ses incivilités
combien de maires ont suivi ces
formations je sais pas vous répondre
aujourd'hui sur le nombre de maires
formés sur ces sujets mais non je sais
pas vous répondre aujourd'hui vous allez
travailler justement à rendre ces
formations encore plus connues pour
qu'elles soient encore plus subies par
les mères ça fait partie de ce dialogue
on ne peut pas contraindre les maires à
aller vers des formations mais dans le
dialogue entre les gendarmes et ce
gendarme référent violence faite aux
élus et l'élu locales il y a forcément
une incitation à cette formation sur la
façon de parler aux jeunes sur un
certain nombre d'outils qui peuvent être
à la disposition des mers et qui sont
pas forcément utilisés il y a un sondage
paru dans le Figaro sondage au doxa pour
Le Figaro pardon qui a été réalisé avant
les émeutes je le précise parce que
c'est important 66 des Français
renonceraient à se présenter à une
élection parce qu'il craindrait pour
leur sécurité ou celle de leur famille
comment vous réagissez à ce chiffre
il est effectivement important c'est pas
ce que je constate c'est parce que nous
travaillons avec David Lisnard et l'AMF
sur les conditions d'exercice du mandat
des lieux locales nous allons annoncer
semaine prochaine déjà un certain nombre
de mesures et surtout une méthodologie
pour être en mesure après avoir
travaillé ensemble élargi à l'ensemble
des associations d'élus pour annoncer au
Congrès des Maires véritablement entre
autres un statut de l'élu en fait vous
avez attendu depuis des années qui
arrivera donc en novembre monsieur le
sénateur précédemment et ce travail
il y aura officiellement un statut de
l'éluge qui est qu'une des composantes
mais majeures dans ces conditions
d'exercice du mandat d'élus et
aujourd'hui ce que je constate qu'il n'y
a peu de corrélation entre les élus qui
démissionnent que je reçois beaucoup et
que je rencontre beaucoup et les élus
qui ont fait l'objet de violence je sens
les élus qu'on fait l'objet de violence
on a le maire de Saint-Brevin bien sûr
on en a quelques-uns mais je dirais
qu'il n'y a que 30% de démission d'élus
qui prennent leurs origines dans le fait
d'avoir fait l'objet de menaces de cette
émission c'est quoi alors c'est la
charge administrative c'est la
complexité c'est la difficulté à
concilier la fonction de maire avec une
vie professionnelle et une vie familiale
David Lessard il parle de harcèlement
textuel ce sont ces mots est-ce que du
coup vous allez mettre fin à ça oui vous
savez comme pour le statut de l'élu ça
fait 30 ans qu'on parle de l'empilement
et des normes et
tous les gouvernements ayant travaillé
oui nous avons déjà travaillé il a
triplé en 20 ans est-ce que du coup vous
allez faire quelque chose pour pour
aider les maires face à ça bien sûr donc
c'est notre objectif et c'est l'objet du
travail que l'on va conduire c'est pour
ça qu'il nous faut autant de temps
jusqu'au mois de novembre pour être en
mesure de bien inventorier parce que
de bien inventorier tout ce qui est
source de difficultés tout ce qui est
complexe et
quand on s'attaque un problème complexe
le découper en problème simple ça paraît
une évidence et c'est ce que nous sommes
en train de faire pour ne pas rester en
boucle sur trop de charges
administratives oui mais par où on
commence et c'est ce travail que nous
avons démarré et c'est en prenant un
petit peu toutes le droit de l'urbanisme
par exemple extrêmement complexe il y a
tout un travail avec toutes les
dimensions environnementales qui ont été
ajoutées aujourd'hui mais repartir à
zéro c'est absolument impossible donc
cette simplification tout le monde
appelle de ses vœux c'est simple à dire
mais après il faut rentrer dans les
textes quand on voit mais ça va être
quoi c'est à dire plus de normes créées
sans que d'autres soient supprimés en
compensation ça existe déjà et ça c'est
vérifié déjà aujourd'hui et
ça marche pas très bien c'est à dire que
oui on continue par en produire
d'énormes mais quand vous voyez
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat qui
porte énormément de projets eux-mêmes
c'est eux qui appellent à de la
simplification mais eux-mêmes apportent
beaucoup de textes moi je sais que la
consigne au gouvernement depuis un an
elle est claire c'est des textes courts
et le moins possible de textes il me
semble que l'on vous parlementaire et il
faut aussi se tenir à ça il faut que
ensemble on essaye effectivement de
porter de moins en moins de textes et
puis qu'il soit de plus en plus court il
y a aussi la question des indemnités les
élus est-ce que est-ce que est-ce que
vous êtes favorable vous soyez favorable
à une augmentation des indemnités des
maires notamment dans les petites
communes oui
un sujet sur lequel nous travaillons
dans ce qu'on appelle le statut de l'élu
on a évidemment la rémunération
l'indemnisation des élus qui va être
au cœur de nos niveaux de collectivité
ah non non mais je peux pas vous dire
aujourd'hui c'est ce que ce à quoi nous
allons aboutir donc oui vous travaillez
il y a une réalité qui fait que
aujourd'hui elle est déjà compensée mais
il nous faut repenser effectivement
cette Inde mnisation
pour pour un maire d'une commune de
moins de 500 habitants est-ce qu'il faut
aller au-delà
ces petites communes là je trouve
qu'elles sont assez bien accompagnées
aujourd'hui mais dès qu'on monte de
strates c'est des effets de seuil on
s'aperçoit que 1000
1500 à 1500 par exemple la rémunération
compte tenu de l'absence d'agents sur
les petites communes c'est le encore
plus le cas mais il y a peu d'agents
pour accompagner le maire et c'est
finalement un travail le maire notamment
il y a un groupe point clé dans les
toutes petites communes et secrétaires
de mairie vous avancez au niveau de la
loi là sur le sur pour valoriser les
statuts et arriver à recruter
suffisamment de nouveaux secrétaires de
mairie oui avec mon collègue Stanislas
Guérini on s'est vraiment attelé à ce
sujet de l'attractivité du métier de
secrétaire de mairie d'abord pour
conserver celle qui sont elles sont si
précieuses aux côtés de nos mères et en
même temps pour être en mesure de
recruter et on a c'est une PPL qui a été
portée par le Sénat et qui a été votée à
l'unanimité donc oui on est on est
vraiment sur le chemin de la
revalorisation de la reconnaissance de
ce métier de secrétaire numérique je
pense que de ce que je vois des échanges
avec dessinateur et avec les mers c'est
très apprécié il nous faut aussi
travailler sur des formations rendre
maintenant les choses opérationnelles
pour que un certain nombre de
secrétaires de mairie nouvelle arrivent
et candidate auprès de des communes ce
qu'on a quand même beaucoup de
secrétaires de mairie qui partent en
retraite donc il nous faut arriver à
véritablement mettre en place des
formations pour qu'on ait des promotions
secrétaire de mairie homme ou femme qui
arrive dans nos collectivités vous qui
êtes chargés de la ruralité est-ce que
la situation actuelle qui s'ajoute déjà
à un sentiment de relégation vous avez
tenté d'y répondre avec le plan de
réalité est-ce que tout ça est un
carburant pour le rassemblement national
en ruralité j'entendais le sénateur dire
qu'il attendait la mise en oeuvre on y
est ça fait trois semaines que
effectivement la première ministre
annonçait France ruralité dans la Vienne
le lendemain de l'annonce nous étions
déjà dans la méthodologie et dans la
mise en œuvre avec la NT avec les
préfets
l'Agence nationale de cohésion des
habitants moi j'y crois vraiment
donc
plutôt que lutter
politiquement contre le rassemblement
national moi je fais en sorte que nos
concitoyens n'est plus par les actions
que l'on conduit et que qui verront des
premiers effets dès la fin de l'année il
y a un certain nombre de mesures simples
qui sont en train d'être déployés et
bien sur votre de révolte reculera plus
nos concitoyens prendront conscience à
quel point petit à petit leur qualité de
vie s'améliore par des actions que nous
conduisons vis-à-vis des Maires et des
Collectivités bien sûr mais aussi
vis-à-vis des associations et vis-à-vis
des commerces je vais avoir aussi une
pensée pour les commerçants qui ont fait
l'objet de violence et la difficulté
auxquelles ils sont confrontés
on y est extrêmement sensible dire au
contraire pour nos élus bien sûr notre
République ne reculera pas et notre
République sera aux côtés des mers mais
aussi un mot pour nos commerçants qui
ont été extrêmement agressés pillées si
beaucoup merci dominicore merci c'est
notre invité ce matin merci Stéphane on
regarde la ligne de Ouest-France et lui
citoyen unit façon violence c'est à la
Une de votre journal merci Stéphane
merci Dominique